california democrats who dreamed
too big by promising big tech its own
subway system
under silicon valley have finally found
a way to pay for their multi-billion
dollar debacle
just sneak it in to the covid relief
bill
chief breaking news correspondent trace
gallagher is here to explain what's
really going on
trace kenny good evening this
underground rail project in the silicon
valley has been really in the planning
stages for several years it still has
not broken ground but
that has not stopped the estimated cost
of the project from rising it was 4.6
billion back in 2018
now it's 6.9 billion the finish date is
supposed to be 2030 by then it could be
15 billion or more and keep in mind they
plan to use the biggest
boring machine in the world to drill the
tunnel
beneath san jose and experts say that
comes with increased risk and cost
plus the san jose mercury news says
local residents are outraged because the
project is eating up
a huge chunk of local sales tax revenue
money that normally goes to roads
bridges and traffic management
and now as you mentioned the house
transportation committee
has put 112 million dollars into the
coven bill
to help fund the train congressional
republicans including
senator tom cotton not very happy watch
what does mass transit in san francisco
have to do
with a global pandemic it has nothing to
do with it it only has to do with nancy
pelosi getting an earmark for her
district
which this bill does across the country
and for the record this would not be the
first federal funding for the silicon
valley's underground train it got 125
million back in 2019
another 100 million earlier this year
and if you're wondering what other pork
might be stuffed into the covent bill
it's got a billion dollars for racial
justice for farmers
200 million for library services
and 10 million for native american
language preservation
just to name a few katie all right trace
gallagher thank you so much